we know them as man's best friend and
while dogs have endeared themselves to
humankind there are not only great
companions but hard workers for
thousands of years dogs have been part
of the human experience they have
adapted and been bred to assist us in
everyday life they play diverse roles as
livestock herders rescuers sled pullers
and even work to brighten the lives of
the elderly and disabled early on in our
relationship dogs found a role within
society their exceptional abilities to
see and run and their protective nature
made them perfect for herding livestock
fending off predators while keeping the
herd moving even in the modern age dogs
are used in farm work in places like the
rugged mountains of New Zealand on an
open range like this
a handful of dogs can handle thousands
of sheep they work tirelessly and cover
up to fifty miles a day routinely but
working the farm isn't the only way they
help their human masters in the frozen
lands of the north indigenous people
relied on dogs as a vital means of
transportation the thick fur and strong
stamina of dogs like the Siberian Husky
made them well adapted to hauling food
and supplies to villages in the cold
weather during the gold rush of the late
19th century they were routinely used to
haul Freight years later sled dogs
carried explorers Admiral Robert Peary
and Roald Amundsen to find the north and
south poles these dogs still ply the
snows of the extreme north their
endurance put to the test in
competitions like the Iditarod dog sled
race dogs often contribute to our lives
by working alongside us but they also
save lives when sudden disasters like an
avalanche or earthquake happen rescue
dogs can find people under near
impossible conditions some qualities of
rescue dogs do come natural
their sense of smell is far superior to
humans but rescue dogs must still work
hard with their trainers to hone their
skills and for the dog it's a game they
learn to sniff out people for the reward
of food and toys in real situations it's
the dog who communicates to the trainer
where people may be trapped and who
commend signal authorities but dogs
don't necessarily have to be the strong
and sturdy types to be workers when it
comes to helping special needs people
with pet therapy the main qualification
is unconditional love these special dogs
spend their days visiting people who
could use some attention for them
spending time with these critters has
led to improve communication that our
attention with tasks and what can often
be a much-needed lifting of spirits for
all their help dogs remain some of our
closest companions